good morning John I hope that you won't
mind if I address my videoblog today to
someone besides you and that person is
the guy who called me a [ __ ] the other
day hello guy who called me a [ __ ] the
other day I you do it's the last week as
I was riding my bike down a fairly busy
street I was thinking about work and I
was thinking about friends and I was
thinking a little bit about making sure
I wouldn't get hit by any cars
bicyclists on roads are very vulnerable
and traffic law and common sense dictate
that we travel with the flow of traffic
and so when cars are coming from behind
us what we can't see them what we're
doing is trusting that they will not use
the power that they have to grind our
pelvises into dust inside of our body
yes it is totally possible that anybody
in a car could do that to a biker if
they wanted to but we are trusting that
you don't want to as well as being an
active trust it's also an act of bravery
I am not so afraid of death that I will
not ride my bike on beautiful days just
because there is a small chance that my
brain will exit its skull because
someone has a very pressing text message
and they're not paying attention to the
road that was not directed at the guy
who called me a [ __ ] that was directed
at everyone now back to the person who
called me a [ __ ] I'm not sure why you
did that as you flew past me in your
3,000 pound truck last week even
assuming the I am on board with your
definition of [ __ ] which to be clear I
am NOT it is the way that you use that
word applies all kinds of assumptions
about gender and weakness and cowardice
that are just not true but since you
probably aren't gonna be able to
understand me if I use grown up words
let's stick with your vernacular
I am very not the [ __ ] in this
situation sir you as it happens are
surrounded by 3000 pounds of Steel and
the most advanced safety equipment that
humanity has yet to create I am
surrounded by air balanced on two
circular wheels using nothing more than
my momentum and precariously placed body
weight your vehicle has a top speed of
around eight times that of my vehicle
and the most advanced safety equipment I
have got is a freaking foam hat are you
sure that I'm the [ __ ] are you sure
that taunting a man on a bicycle while
you are sitting in what is in effect
freakin bulletproof MechWarrior is not
the act of a coward you think you are
brave what you are is safe bravery is
not strength in the face of a far lesser
foe bravery is the exact opposite of
that your need to exert your dominance
over me and that
situation is in fact an indication of
really severe cowardice unless this is
some kind of bizarre experiment in irony
that I don't quite get it must be really
hard for you to live your life as that
much of a coward so for that I'm sorry
you have my pity in fact I want to make
that very clear I pity you
I originally wrote this rant on my
tumblr link below I freaking love tumblr
but what I didn't say in that tongue
blog for a long time after the incident
a long time after this guy called me a
[ __ ] for no apparent reason I could not
help but think what did I do wrong why
did he think I was a [ __ ]
I have every right to a very healthy ego
yet one comment from someone who I never
saw had me thinking what is wrong with
me
do I look wrong do I act wrong is there
something wrong with me of course
there's not of course the problem is
with the douchebag Ali Khan a young lady
asked me how I dealt with bullying and I
wasn't able to give her a very good
answer which troubles me there are lots
of shouts if it gets better and stays
strong and we love you when I put myself
back in time to when I was being bullied
none of those things would have helped
me yes absolutely it does get better
when you are being physically and
psychologically tortured it is difficult
to remove yourself from the pressing
nosov the moment at hand here's how I
dealt with bullying I cried I hated
myself I hated my life I didn't deal
with it I survived it but I never dealt
with it so here are two tips from
someone with lots of experience one it's
not about you it has nothing to do with
you it's about the [ __ ] doing it to
you and to your job is not to deal with
it your job is to survive it which you
can do because it will end and then yes
it will get better
John I'll see you on Wednesday